[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
كيف تبدأ في شرح
كوابيس هذه
الحرب لهؤلاء
الأطفال المصابين في حالة ذهول ويحزنون الآن على
جسد حمود الصغير الذي لا حياة فيه وهو
يحتضن بين ذراعي والده الذي
قُتل في غارة على
مخيم جباليا الشمالي  في منطقة دي البلح الوسطى،
المزيد من الوداع، ومع ذلك، هرع المزيد من الأطفال الذين
قتلوا والجرحى إلى مستشفى كان
على وشك
الانهيار بالفعل، كما يقولون، أثناء
محاولتهم الإخلاء
جنوبًا
[موسيقى]
في الشمال، لم يتبق الآن سوى
مستشفى واحد قيد
التشغيل.  راحة مشلولة بسبب
نقص الوقود والأدوية
والإمدادات الأساسية مع مرور كل يوم في
مستشفى الشايفر، وهو أكبر مستشفى في غزة، هناك
المزيد من الجثث ولكن لم تعد هناك مساحة
في
مستودعات المستشفى اليوم، كانت هناك مبادرة من
المدنيين داخل المستشفى بأن
المدينة أصبحت  فظيع وبدأوا
الحفر في أه داخل المستشفى
لدفن الجثث على
مسؤوليتهم الخاصة دون أي
ترتيبات من
جانب الإسراء مع عدم وجود إمدادات أكسجين في
المستشفى اضطر الأطباء في علاء
إلى إخراج الأطفال المبتسرين من
حاضناتهم صرخات  الأشخاص الأكثر
ضعفًا في غزة متجمعون معًا ملفوفون في
الرقائق والبطانيات لإبقائهم دافئين،
ويقول الجيش الإسرائيلي إنه عرض
تزويد "الشيفر" بمزيد من الحاضنات
والدعم في إجلاء
الأطفال، لكن لم تتم مشاركة أي تفاصيل
حول كيفية المضي قدمًا في خطة الإخلاء
بهذا المطلب الأساسي  بالنسبة
لمستشفى الشفاء، تشغيل المستشفى الإندونيسي
مثل الوقود،
هناك حاجة ملحة إلى إدخال وخروج آمنين للإمدادات الطبية، وقد رأت إسرائيل منذ
فترة طويلة أن حماس قد وضعت
مركزًا للقيادة والسيطرة أسفل
ادعاء مستشفى إليفا الذي ردده الآن
المسؤولون الأمريكيون، ولم تتمكن CNN من التحقق من هذا
الادعاء الذي تم
نفته حماس
والمسؤولون الطبيون على الأرض بشدة، حيث أعرب العديد من الأطباء عن
قلقهم إزاء الاقتراحات التي تشير إلى
إمكانية اعتبار المستشفيات الآن
أهدافًا للطاقم الطبي من منظمة أطباء
بلا حدود، قائلين يوم الثلاثاء إن
الرصاص أطلق على أحد مباني منظمة أطباء بلا حدود الثلاثة
بالقرب من الشيفر مع
قتال عنيف في  المنطقة المجاورة
يقول الجيش الإسرائيلي إنه سمح
بمسار إخلاء من المستشفى لكن
الطاقم الطبي يقول إنه من شبه المستحيل
إخلاء المرضى والمدنيين بأمان
وسط القصف المستمر لقد
تلقينا مئات المكالمات
لبكاء الناس وهم محاصرون
في منازلهم في غزة  في المدينة
والشمال، فإنهم غير قادرين على إخلاء
منازلهم لأن المنطقة بأكملها تشهد
عملية عسكرية، وببساطة فإن أي
شخص يحاول الخروج سيكون هدفًا
للجيش الإسرائيلي، والعديد من المرضى ببساطة
مريضون للغاية بحيث لا يمكنهم الشروع في المشي الطويل والخطير.
إلى جنوب
غزة، يموت بعض مثل هذا الطفل الصغير
في
الطريق، ولكن حتى في الجنوب، في المناطق التي
حددتها
الغارات الجوية الإسرائيلية القاتلة على أنها مناطق آمنة،
يواصل أفراد الأسرة والطاقم الطبي
الوقوف جنبًا إلى جنب لأداء
صلاة الجنازة للكثيرين  في غزة الآن
طقوس يومية NE بشير سي إن إن في
القدس